und jetzt das heute journal
mit heinz wolf und marietta slomka
genannt es beginnt eine weitere woche im
aufnahmemodus die einst normale welt in
der man freunde und familie umarmte mit
kollegen eng beieinander saß
urlaubsreisen plante ins restaurant
bringen oder schnell mal im supermarkt
wc-papier besorgte diese normale welt
scheint ja schon jetzt eigenartig weit
weg dabei stehen wir ja gerade erst am
anfang dieser kollektiven anstrengung
vielleicht sieht man am ende der woche
schon eine kleine tendenz für eine
eindeutige datenlage wird es aber wohl
noch länger dauern
angesichts all dieser ungewissheiten ist
es schon schwierig exakte prognosen zu
erstellen welche folgen dieses
runterfahren von gesellschaft und
wirtschaft haben wird
die sogenannten wirtschaftsweisen haben
das heute trotzdem getan mit dem hinweis
dass sie zwar keine kristallkugel haben
aber man zitat im dunklen auch nicht die
taschenlampe ausknipsen sollte welche
szenarien der heute beleuchtet wurden
erläutert andreas opitz ein
risikoszenario das ist ja eine
außergewöhnliche lage ist gegner den wir
jetzt haben man kann jetzt nicht ein
halbes dreiviertel jahr aussetzen
eine wirtschaftliche bestandsaufnahme
gesendet aus dem digitalen raum hinein
in die deutsche volkswirtschaft führende
ökonomen die weisen der wirtschaft haben
ein sondergutachten erstellt präsentiert
per videochat grüße herzlich zu unserer
pressekonferenz heute einer virtuellen
virtuell hin oder her
das gutachten ist geprägt durch das
corona virus die szenarien darin fassen
den einfluss durch die pandemie auf die
deutsche wirtschaft in zahlen was unser
risikoszenario ist da geht die
wirtschaftsleistung in deutschland
tatsächlich im ersten und zweiten
quartal zusammen genommen relativ zum
ausgang anfang des jahres um zehn
prozent zurück zehn prozent ist schon
eine ganze menge aufs komplette jahr
gerechnet ergeben sich zwei verläufe ein
noch relativ guter der durch das zügige
anlaufen der wirtschaft ein gesamtjahres
minus von 2,8 prozent ergibt und ein
relativ schlechter der ein minus von 5,4
prozent ergeben würde
die bundesregierung ist gefordert das -
so gering
wie möglich zu halten die sorge ist ja
dass durch diese pandemie schäden
entstehen in der wirtschaftsstruktur die
viele jahre fortwirken werden das müssen
wir verhindern
ich glaube das können wir verhindern und
deshalb bin ich froh dass die ersten
sofortmaßnahmen jetzt auch greifen wir
sind also bei allen schwierigkeiten war
eine größere herausforderung gut
gewappnet für diese zeit und wir sind
entschlossen als bundesregierung das zu
tun um die menschen sorgen von der
schulter zu nehmen sorgen um die
gesundheit aber eben sorgen auch um die
wirtschaftliche existenz
die opposition wirft der regierung vor
es fehle ein klarer plan ein
investitionsprogramm zur wiederbelebung
der deutschen wirtschaft
es ist richtig den appell der
wirtschaftsweisen heute schon so zu
verstehen die planung für die
investition jetzt schon vorzunehmen dass
wir danach nicht viel zeit verlieren
sondern dieses konjunkturprogramm dann
schnell anschieben können zu recht haben
auch die wirtschaftsweisen jetzt noch
mal darauf hingewiesen dass die auch zur
verantwortungsvollen eindämmung der
wirtschaftlichen folgen die zu erwarten
sind
das auch da eine klare kommunikation
besonders wichtig ist damit sich alle
beteiligten darauf einstellen können
wie lange nach welchen kriterien welche
einschränkungen notwendig sind alles
hängt also auch an der frage wann kann
man wieder zurück in den alltag wann
zurück zur geregelten arbeit bayern hat
heute klar gemacht so schnell wird das
nichts
es gibt keinen anlass falsche hoffnungen
zu wecken und es ist keine zeit für
einen vorschnellen exit oder
entsprechende debatten corona hat die
deutsche wirtschaft infiziert erst
langsam jetzt explosionsartig
wir haben eine klare prioritätensetzung
schutz der gesundheit sicherung von
arbeitsplätzen und gewährleistung von
sozialer sicherheit das ist jetzt das
was auf der tagesordnung steht später
werden wir darüber reden wie wir die
wirtschaft auch wieder ankurbeln müssen
im moment steht in unserer arbeit
eindeutig die bewältigung dieser
herausforderungen der krankheit im
vordergrund und so wird es die nächsten
wochen auch bleiben niemand kann heute
sagen wie lange das corona virus
deutschland noch im würgegriff hält
davon hängt letztlich ab wie stark die
wirtschaft darunter leiden wird
darüber wollen wir noch reden mit dem
vorsitzenden des sachverständigenrats
gewissermaßen der oberste
wirtschaftsweise professor lars feld
seinen lehrstuhl an der universität
freiburg hat genannt der professor feld
von anfangs linke selbst in dem am
wenigsten düsteren szenario dass sie
heute vorgestellt haben ist die aussicht
darauf in eine rezession zu rutschen
doch quasi unausweichlich helfen denn
die gegenmaßnahmen der regierung gar
nicht ging zu steuern
nun die gegenmaßnahmen die bisher
ergriffen worden sind dienen ja vor
allen dingen dazu über die nächsten
wochen hinweg zu kommen
klassische konjunkturprogramme nutzen in
einer solchen phase wenig wenn man den
leuten mehr geld gibt
dann würden sie das ja auch gerne
ausgeben das können sie in der
gegenwärtigen lage ja nicht sie soll in
der er zu hause bleiben und diese
liquiditätsmaßnahmen maßnahmen helfen
sehr wohl was kann denn darüber hinaus
geschehen oder welche erwartungen haben
sie dann noch nun zunächst einmal geht
es darum dass wir insbesondere in dieser
struktur der probleme die jetzt da vor
uns liegen angesichts der betroffenen
branchen sicherstellen dass insolvenzen
so gut es geht vermieden werden können
das ist nicht so ganz einfach da es sich
ja häufig um kleine unternehmen handelt
die nicht einfach einen weiteren kredit
schulden schultern können
von daher ist es sehr wichtig dass auch
die zuschüsse schnell ausgezahlt werden
wenn uns das gelingt und wir nach dem
zwanzigsten april wieder relativ rasch
an die arbeit zurück können dann bin ich
ganz zuversichtlich dass es gar nicht so
viele an anstoß von seiten der
bundesregierung braucht vielleicht das
eine oder andere was man im steuerlichen
bereich macht ein vorziehen des
solidaritätszuschlags oder vielleicht
sogar seine vollständige abschaffung
oder auf der ausgabenseite bei den
investitionsprogrammen die ja sowieso in
den nächsten jahren hochgefahren werden
sollten
eine schnellere reaktion die
bauwirtschaft ist vielleicht ja auch
nicht mehr in der über auslastung sind
ja nicht alle branchen gleichermaßen
betroffen es gibt womöglich sogar
krisengewinnler ohne das jetzt zumindest
verstehe
haben zu wollen aber branchen die im
moment ja auch weiter funktionieren es
gibt ja nicht das gesamte
wirtschaftsleben jetzt schon brach und
befürchten sie dass das dann indirekt
durch effekte doch noch so kommen
wollten den nächsten wochen ich erwarte
nicht dass die ganze wirtschaft brach
liegt
wir beschreiben das ja ganz gut
wir haben schon eine ganze reihe von
branchen die relativ gut laufen
gegenwärtig immer noch und auch eine in
den vergangenen jahren durch die massive
über auslastung gekennzeichnete
bauwirtschaft ist im moment ja nicht zum
stillstand gekommen wir haben natürlich
stark betroffenen branchen die
insbesondere in den im bereich der
dienstleistungen anzutreffen sind also
das gastgewerbe beispielsweise den
einzelhandel tourismus transport
dort liegen größere probleme wir sehen
auch im industriellen bereich wo es
darauf ankommt dass internationalisierte
wertschöpfungsketten die produktion
bedienen dass wir nicht in dem maße
produzieren können beispielsweise im
automobilsektor aber wenn sie jetzt
beispielsweise ein medizinprodukte
denken die firma träger läuft drei
schichten produktion träger macht
beatmungsgeräte oder oder lieferdienste
und ähnliches wenn man sich jetzt mal
ansieht wie es deutschland nach der
finanzkrise den 2009 da war ein einbruch
von 5,7 prozent
und das galt als gewaltig aber man hat
es überlebt glauben sie dass es diesmal
schlimmer wird nun bei das ganze jahr
gerechnet 5,4 prozent landen wir bereits
in unserem risikoszenario das
wahrscheinlichere szenario wenn die
maßnahmen die jetzt ergriffen worden
sind
das kontaktverbot nur bis zum
zwanzigsten april geht und wir danach
allmählich wieder an die arbeit
zurückkehren können
dann kann das wirtschaftswachstum auch
in geringerem ausmaß zurückgehen
aufs ganze jahr gesehen dann landen wir
nur bei minus 2,8 prozent nur in
anführungszeichen denn das jetzt gerade
bevorstehenden zweiten quartal sehr wohl
dass der einbruch kräftig ist man
konzentrieren sich alle auch heute dann
in ihren aussagen auf diesen neunzehnten
oder zwanzigster april das muss jetzt so
ein virus nicht unbedingt interessieren
dass da die osterferien zu ende sind
es könnte also auch noch länger dauern
sie kennen diese diskussion darüber dass
man ab werk zwischen
gesundheitspolitischen maßnahmen
stichwort leben retten und den auch zum
teil fatalen folgen an einer schwersten
schwersten wirtschaftskrise wie stehen
sie zu dieser debatte
ich finde dass man diesen zielkonflikt
nicht einfach als er in eindimensionalen
zielkonflikt aufmachen darf denn
einerseits ist es so dass dann wenn es
uns gelingt gesundheitspolitisch die
ausbreitung des virus einzudämmen und
die todesfälle die damit verbunden sind
so gering wie möglich zu halten dass wir
eben auch mittel und langfristig davon
wirtschaftlich zählen können dass die
arbeitskräfte wieder alle zur verfügung
stehen und weil die menschen auch ganz
normal weiter konsumieren können und auf
der anderen seite ist es schon auch
wichtig dass wir die wirtschaftlichen
gesichtspunkte die kurzfristigen rolle
spielen blick haben muss also beide
sehen und versuchen nun in der phase in
der wir sind
die infektionszahlen möglichst niedrig
zu halten damit das gesundheitssystem
nicht überlastet ist und dann auf der
anderen seite sich dann auch genau
überlegen ab welchem zeitpunkt wir
wieder in die normalität zurückkehren
können wenn es dann wieder zu
ansteckungen kommt wird man auch
flexibel darauf reagieren müssen in der
hoffnung dass bis dahin medikamente zur
verfügung stehen und dass wir dann auch
bis zum herbst zur spätestens zum winter
einen impfstoff zur verfügung haben auch
diese kombinationen sind ja alle mit zu
bedenken wenn es um die wirtschaftlichen
folgen geht auf dem stoff tragen alle
herr professor fällt dank interest
gespräch ich danke ihnen versauen kann
die tourismus branche gehört natürlich
zu denen die es besonders hart trifft
umzubuchen aufs nächste jahr oder
gutscheine zu akzeptieren statt ganz zu
stornieren hilft zwar aber das will und
kann nicht jeder kunde in deutschland
ist mecklenburg vorpommern eines der
bundesländer für die der tourismus
besonders wichtiger wirtschaftsfaktor
ist all die feriengebiete an der ostsee
oder an der seenplatte trifft das hart
die landesregierung regelt auch
tatsächlich rigoros ab für meck pomm
gilt für touristische zwecke ein
striktes einreiseverbot
so sollen auch berliner zum beispiel
nicht auf die idee kommen über ostern
zum picknicken an die müritz zu fahren
oder ähnliches auf den straßen wird das
auch kontrolliert wie hotels und
gastronomen mit der situation umgehen
berichtet ganz mosebach der strand von
warnemünde weit und leer liegt er in der
frühlingssonne
die urlauber mussten das land verlassen
eine vollbremsung für den tourismus in
mecklenburg vorpommern in guten zeiten
serviert rené gildemeister speisen und
getränke im warnemünder hof jetzt
renoviert er die zimmer des hauses
anderswo haben die hoteliers ihre leute
in kurzarbeit geschickt oder gar
entlassen
hier setzt man auf arbeitsbeschaffung
natürlich sind wir froh dass das hotel
und es diese möglichkeit gibt das halt
noch andere arbeiten zu machen sind dass
wenn ich in kurzarbeit gehen müssen
das modell nicht schließt wir haben alle
familien zu hause und es sind halt ein
paar wenige die sind natürlich sonst
auch verhindern
70 mitarbeiter beschäftigt das
vier-sterne-hotel jeder tut was er kann
150.000 euro personalkosten los direktor
frank martens monatlich aufbringen
er will den hotelbetrieb
aufrechterhalten auch ohne gäste wir
haben mitarbeiterversammlung gemacht wo
wir die die situation erklärt haben war
natürlich eine große angst auch bei den
mitarbeitern waren und haben dann
wirklich so eine pinnwand aufgebaut und
gefragt so wer kann was und haben dann
alle namen durch gehabt und eben unter
jeder spalte inklusive nach dienst den
wir dann auch selber machen müssen
hat sich jemand eingetragen
auch in der küche wird noch gearbeitet
wenn auch auf sparflamme
chefkoch jahn reinhardt hat auf außer
haus verkauf umgestellt und dann geht's
auf reisen vor allem stammgäste nutzen
das angebot ein lieferservice wurde
ebenfalls eingerichtet
rund um den alten strom dem
touristischen zentrum von warnemünde
sind seit einer woche alle geschäfte
geschlossen
die vor saison fällt aus das
ostergeschäft ebenfalls peter rickert
hat seinen souvenirladen aus dem januar
eröffnet 80.000 euro investiert
gemeinsam mit seiner frau wollte sich
der handwerker damit ein zweites
standbein schaffen kein guter start
die einnahmen die kosten bleiben aber
das ist leider so mit der versicherung
steuerberater und finanzamt usw
es trifft die kleinen und die großen der
tourismusbranche 150.000 arbeitsplätze
hängen in mecklenburg vorpommern am
geschäft mit den urlaubern wir haben
umfragen gemacht wonach auch heute schon
20 prozent mit entlassungen planen das
natürlich das was wir nicht wollen
wo heute jeder fünfzehnte schon sagt
dass er möglicherweise vor eine
geschäftsaufgabe steht mecklenburg
vorpommern hat sich seit der wende zum
tourismusland nummer eins in deutschland
entwickelt die landesregierung hat ein
nothilfeprogramm aufgelegt wir haben
einen schutz von für mecklenburg
vorpommern aufgestellt von 1,1
milliarden euro davon gehen alleine 800
millionen euro für die sicherung von
unternehmen und arbeitsplätze und da
natürlich auch der fokus insbesondere
für touristische betriebe und das geld
reicht erstmal bis zum 19 april
das sind drei wochen
während der schließung hotel oder kneipe
zu renovieren das natürlich eine gute
idee wenn man es sich leisten kann und
dass er demnächst mal angestanden hätte
und wenn man guten mutes ist die korona
zeit wirtschaftlich zu überleben
andere unternehmen suchen jetzt nach
ganz neuen aufgaben und produktions
feldern zb im gesundheitsbereich valerie
haller da gibt es in der deutschen
unternehmerschaft schon durchaus
kreative idee ja not macht eben doch
erfinderisch bei vielen unternehmen sind
die auftragsbücher leer und sie suchen
jetzt händeringend nach möglichkeiten
freie kapazitäten zu nutzen andere
produkte im gesundheitsbereich wiederum
werden ja dringend gebraucht und daher
stellen jetzt einige unternehmen ihre
produktion um vielleicht für den einen
oder anderen auch ein weg sich über
wasser zu halten
atemschutzmasken schutzausrüstung teile
für beatmungsgeräte die autoindustrie
will mit 3d druckern aushelfen die
textilbranche mit masken und ausrüstung
desinfektionsmittel sind oft mangelware
kosmetik hersteller haben ihre
produktion umgewidmet getränkehersteller
liefern hochprozentigen reinigungs
alkohol
weltweit engagieren sich immer mehr
unternehmen im kampf gegen die korona
krise sie nehmen aber nicht nur
mundschutz oder mission
desinfektionsmittel
sie verleihen auch mitarbeiter spenden
material der nutzen einzelner aktionen
mag manchmal umstritten sein aber die
unternehmen zeigen damit dass sie sich
dem virus nicht hilflos ausliefern
wollen mutmacher in zeiten voller sorge
gut fürs image ist es obendrein
dankeschön weil er nach frankfurt
improvisieren neue wege gehen das tun
nicht nur unternehmen in zahlreichen
deutschen wohnzimmern werden neuerdings
ja videokonferenzen abgehalten nicht nur
wegen home office sondern auch zum
privaten meeting mit freunden und
verwandten
es soll auch nicht weniger groß eltern
geben die sich jetzt entsprechende
konferenz apps erklären lassen oder
erstmals skype oder facetime benutzen um
die enkel wenigstens virtuell zu sehen
not macht nicht nur erfinderisch man
wird auch aufgeschlossen haben und so
manch einer überwindet da gerade seinen
bisher stoisch gepflegte technik skepsis
ganz wichtig wird das jetzt auch im
gesundheitswesen werden stichwort
telemedizin
dabei geht es nicht nur um betreuung von
patienten zum beispiel durch hausärzte
vor allem für krankenhäuser kann es in
der korona krise geradezu essentiell
werden sich mit größeren unikliniken auf
diesem wege zu beraten und expertise
einzuholen
die universitätsklinik aachen ist da ein
vorreiter berichtet dominik müller russe
ungewöhnliche visite heute mittag auf
der isolierstation des krankenhauses
türen beim cupid 19 patienten ludwig rom
bei 75 jahre alt und zum glück fast
wieder genesen meldet sich aus dem
laptop der sogenannte telemedizin das
uniklinikum aachen heute assistiert vom
nordrhein westfälischen
ministerpräsidenten das projekt
virtuelles krankenhaus ist der medizin
bereich der stolz des landes nordrhein
westfalen
es funktioniert so im tele medizin
zentrum der unikliniken aachen und
münster arbeiten insgesamt 30 ärzte
spezialisten der intensivmedizin sie
unterstützen ihre kollegen draußen in
den kleineren krankenhäusern im land die
nicht die expertise einer großen
uniklinik besitzen und sie behandeln die
patienten dort mit aus der ferne
man sieht den patienten man hört die
ärzte draußen im land und man hat auch
die krankenakten so dass von hier aus in
notfällen beraten werden kann und das
ist unser mittel die kapazitäten zu
verdoppeln
damit jeder der intensiv medizin braucht
sie auch bekommt 5.500 intensivbetten
gibt es in nrw etwas weniger als die
hälfte davon bei den top ausgestatteten
maximal versorgern wie der uniklinik
aachen
etwas mehr als die hälfte stehen in den
kleineren krankenhäusern der grund und
regelversorgung
auf die kommt es nun in der krise an mit
19 patienten sind patienten für
maximalversorger für
universitätskliniken
aber wir brauchen jetzt jedes gerät wir
brauchen jedes intensiv und durch das
virtuelle krankenhaus nrw gelingt ist
jetzt dass wir alle betten wirklich und
alle kolleginnen kollegen wirklich
zusammen bringen und den patienten die
optimale versorgung ermöglichen eine
aufwertung der kleineren krankenhäuser
und gleichzeitig lassen sich so einige
wenige hotspots im land vermeiden die
sich um alle schweren fälle selbst
kümmern müssen und schnell an ihre
grenzen stoßen würden 41 corona
patienten versorgen sie an der uniklinik
aachen
25 von ihnen auf der intensivstation sie
sind vorbereitet für mehr und haben nun
platz für 150 intensivpatienten
geschafft die ungewissheit wie viele
patienten kommen und wie schwer krank
design werden die haben wir natürlich
alle aber wir arbeiten alle schon lange
auf intensivstationen hier in der
uniklinik betreuen wir auch seit langem
schwer kranker patienten als wir kennen
dieses patient klientel am krankenhaus
düren sind sie regelmäßig im austausch
mit der erfahrenen benachbarten
uniklinik und froh über die gespräche
angesichts einer neuen erkrankung
größeren patientenpopulation die in der
uniklinik behandelt wird in unserer
therapiekonzepte und behandlungskonzepte
aufzunehmen und einfach für diese fälle
zu diskutieren das ist schon sehr sehr
wertvoll für uns
visite beendet patient so gut wie
genießen so schnell wie möglich so viele
kliniken wie möglich sollen sich in nrw
nun dem projekt virtuelles krankenhaus
anschließen
vieles geht ja virtuell auch privat aber
die direkte begegnung auf das merkt man
in diesen wochen kann das nicht ersetzen
kein chat kein video ersetzt eine
umarmung
besonders hart trifft es derzeit
liebespaare die das pech haben im
deutschschweizer grenzgebiet zu lieben
viele können sich jetzt nur noch über
den grenzzaun umarmen bei konstanz zum
beispiel hat sich ein regelrechter
pärchen treff entwickelt
denn wer getrennte wohnsitze hat und
nicht verheiratet ist kann den zaun bis
auf weiteres nicht überwinden nur
berufspendler dürfen rein
die freundin oder den freunden der
schweiz zu besuchen gilt nicht als
triftiger grund
weitere meldungen rund um corona hat
jetzt jana becker und beginnt ihren
überblick mit den aktuellen zahlen für
deutschland
in deutschland liegt die zahl der
bestätigten infektionen am abend bei
knapp 64.000 insgesamt soll es bisher
560 todesfälle gegeben haben
über 9200 menschen sind genesen etwa
200.000 deutsche urlauber waren wegen
der korona virus krise im ausland
gestrandet bundesaußenminister maß teilt
heute mit dass seit beginn der
rückholaktion vor zwei wochen bereits
175.000 wieder in deutschland angekommen
sein
in niedersachsen sollen 22 reha kliniken
rund 2000 nicht mit dem corona virus
infizierte patienten von regulären
krankenhäusern übernehmen ebenfalls in
niedersachsen hat gesundheitsministerin
reimann einen aufnahmestopp für
pflegeheime angeordnet ausnahmen gebe es
nur wenn eine 14-tägige quarantäne für
neue bewohner gewährleistet sei zuvor
waren mehrere infizierte
pflegebedürftige in wolfsburg gestorben
auch new york will seine krankenhäuser
durch die verlegung von nicht
infizierten patienten entlasten
dazu ist heute ein krankenhaus schiff
der us-marine eingetroffen und hat
dessen verlängert us-präsident trampe
die verhaltensrichtlinien für das ganze
land bis ende april
wenn am ende nicht mehr als 100.000
menschen ums leben kämen wäre das laut
rampf an guter ausgang für die usa
als erstes westeuropäisches land hat
österreich eine verpflichtung zum tragen
von mund- und nasenschutz in
supermärkten angekündigt bundeskanzler
kurz sagte dies sei pflicht sobald die
masken vor den supermärkten ausgehändigt
werden könnten
die ersten würden dies am mittwoch
schaffen sie müssen mit ihrem auftritt
bis zum kommenden jahr warten nach der
angekündigten verschiebung der
olympischen spiele in tokio steht nun
der neue termin beginnen sollen die
spieler am 23 juli 2021 darauf haben
sich das ioc und die organisatoren
geeinigt
viele weitere infos videos und
hintergründe finden sie bei uns
natürlich auch online auf zdf heute und
jetzt gibt es erstmal andere nachrichten
zu anderen themen von heinz wolf nach
der zweiten runde der kommunalwahl in
bayern gestern sind jetzt die stimmen
ausgezählt bei der stichwahl in der
landeshauptstadt münchen ist
oberbürgermeister dieter reiter von der
spd in seinem amt bestätigt worden die
spd die waren auch in ingolstadt und
bamberg verlor aber ihre
kommunalpolitische hochburg nürnberg an
die csu
die nato hat ihr 30 das mitglied
begrüßten laut mazedonien ist dem
bündnis beigetreten vor dem
nato-hauptquartier in brüssel wurde
heute die flagge des weltbank am
westbalkan landesgericht möglich wurde
der beitritt erst durch eine
namensänderung vergangenes jahr von
mazedonien zu nord mazedonien
zuvor hatte das land jahrzehntelang mit
griechenland wegen einer gleichnamigen
region gestritten
als nächstes will nord mazedonien in die
eu eintreten
im jemen gibt es weiter schwere gefechte
die von saudi arabien angeführte
militärkoalition hat stellungen der
rebellen in der hauptstadt sana'a aus
der luft angegriffen
zuvor hatten am samstag die
houthi-rebellen eine rakete in richtung
saudischen hauptstadt riad abgefeuert
die aber von der saudi-arabischen
luftwaffe abgefangen wurde und dem
norden jemens kam es offenbar zu
schweren kämpfen zwischen jemenitischen
regierungstruppen und rebellen mit
zahlreichen toten auf beiden seiten
in syrien haben mitglieder der terror
organisation die es eine
gefängnisrevolte angezettelt ob dabei
insassen geflohen sind ist unklar
eine kurdische anti terror einheit habe
den aufstand mittlerweile
niedergeschlagen und das gefängnis
gesichert die lage sei unter kontrolle
heißt es von offizieller seite
unter den gefangenen in dem von kurden
kontrollierten gebiet im nordosten
syriens sollen sich viele ausländer
befinden dass ungarns regierungschef
viktor orban das westliche modell
freiheitliche demokratie nicht
sonderlich attraktiv findet
ist altbekannt er setzt dem sein bild
der liberalen demokratie entgegen die es
mit rechtsstaatlicher gewaltenteilung
also den sogenannten checks und balances
nicht so hat und kritiker generell für
relativ überflüssig hält opposition
unabhängiger journalismus widerspruch
von gerichten etc
das ist alles eher lästig innerhalb der
europäischen union gab es deshalb ja
schon in der vergangenheit massive
spannungen
nun aber im zuge der korona krise geht
aber noch einige schritte weiter
berichtet wolf christian ullrich wenn
der freie journalist peter korn ob
derzeit über corona berichten die dann
aus dem homeoffice unabhängige
informationen über die ausbreitung des
corona virus in ungarn findet er kaum
und das neue notstandsgesetz macht es
für ihn jetzt noch schwieriger zu
berichten ohne die nötigen informationen
können unabhängige journalist nur noch
meinungsjournalismus machen und jetzt
ist zu erwarten dass man dafür mit
gefängnis bestraft wird
er meint das neue notstandsgesetz
ministerpräsident orban kann jetzt auf
unbestimmte zeit am parlament vorbei
regieren und orbáns
nationalkonservativer vieles blog hat im
parlament heute außerdem beschlossen
keine wahlen solange der not statt
dauert bis zu acht jahre haft bei
verstößen gegen quarantäne und bis zu
fünf jahre haft bei verbreitung von
falschmeldungen über die korona krise
damit hätte die regierung
sanktionsmittel gegen kritische berichte
die opposition ist entsetzt
das notstandsgesetz ermöglicht der
regierung für unbegrenzte zeit einfach
geltendes recht außer acht zu lassen
das parlament kann heute nur noch als
theater betrachtet werden
jedes land versucht auf seine eigenen
maßnahmen nach ihren eigenen maßstäben
zu finden sagt dagegen der
regierungssprecher aus dem home office
und genau das macht auch ungarn opern
inszeniert sich derweil als
krisenmanager nimmt
öffentlichkeitswirksam eine chinesische
lieferung von hilfsgütern entgegen
kritik aus der eu kümmert ihn nicht er
spürt wie der einst große rückhalt in
der bevölkerung langsam bröckelt das
neue notstandsgesetz soll nun seine
macht zementieren soll ihn als starken
mann zeigen dazu gehört auch dass
neuerdings militär auf den straßen
poliert sogar in betrieben und
krankenhäusern sind jetzt offiziere zur
kontrolle eingesetzt
die budapester sehen das alles mit
einigem fatalismus
ich glaube noch totaler kann er doch gar
nicht mehr das land beherrschen sagt
dieser junge mann der virus kam ihm
gerade recht meint eine frau
die maßnahmen sollen auch kaschieren wie
desolat die lage im gesundheitswesen
derzeit ist ich arbeite daran dass
ausreichend mittel zur verfügung stehen
wenn durch massenhafte erkrankungen eine
große belastung auf das
gesundheitssystem zukommt beteuert orban
heute doch genau diese
gesundheitsversorgung habe die regierung
doch chronisch unterfinanziert beklagt
die opposition so wobei das
gesundheitssystem in ungarn hat in den
letzten zehn jahren großen schaden
erlitten bands politik bestand darin eu
geld aus dem gesundheitswesen oder
andere projekte zu verwenden
über das alles möchte journalist peter
korn ob jetzt während der korona krise
berichten
das gesetz macht unsere arbeit
eigentlich unmöglich meint sein
redakteur während einer video
besprechung aber wir arbeiten weiter
auch wenn wir dafür bestraft werden
man versucht hundertprozentig die chance
zu nutzen um die letzten reste der
rechtsstaatlichkeit zu beseitigen in
ungarn bleibt zu hause lässt die
regierung plakatieren das
notstandsgesetz das corona bekämpfen
soll sturz ungarns demokratie noch
weiter in die krise
und jetzt nochmal heinz wolf mit
weiteren meldungen
die verbraucherpreise sind jetzt im märz
weniger stark gestiegen als zu beginn
dieses jahres bei durchschnittlich 1,4
prozent lag die teuerung im
jahresvergleich hat das statistische
bundesamt anhand erster daten errechnet
im januar und februar waren es noch
jeweils 1,7 prozent haushaltsenergie und
kraftstoffe waren knapp ein prozent
günstiger als vor einem jahr
nahrungsmittel dagegen 3,7 prozent
teurer aus einem niederländischen museum
ist ein gemälde von vincent van gogh
gestohlen worden wie die polizei
mitteilte hatten diebe in der nacht die
gläserne eingangstür des museums im
jahren bei amsterdam aufgebrochen
bei dem gestohlenen waren gogh gemälde
handelt es sich um das werk der
pfarrgarten in lünen mit weiblicher
figur von 1884 wegen der korona pandemie
ist das museum derzeit geschlossen
nachdem fast sommerlichen wochenende ist
in teilen deutschlands der winter noch
einmal zurückgekehrt mit schnee und
temperaturen unter null heute morgen zum
beispiel in ueckermünde am stettiner
haff weiß war es auch in hamburg dort
mussten viele autofahrer wieder kratzen
und räumfahrzeuge ihren dienst noch
einmal antreten er heute frei hatte
konnte mit etwas abstand den schnee
genießen der über mehrere stunden liegen
blieb das war es von uns im
heute-journal und wer sich jetzt von
nachrichten und corona ablenken will
kann das mit einem opulenten schlacht
schinken im montagskino tun
der great wall ein action epos aus dem
alten ziehen und danach um 23 45 gibt es
mit uns gibt's morgen wieder auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
einen schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter das umfangreiche
hoch vor island ist immer noch
tonangebend und auf seiner ostseite
bekommen wir auch noch kühle luft aber
die erwärmt sich in den nächsten tagen
das hoch verschwindet allmählich
richtung westen dann gibt es noch einmal
zum freitag kühle luft aus dem
nordwesten aber spätestens zum
wochenende wird es wärmer ein neues
kleines hoch setzt sich durch und bringt
deutlich wärmere luft aus dem südwesten
mit
in der nacht gibt es in der mitte
deutschlands viele worte und es schneit
den mittelgebirgen bildet sich durchaus
eine schneedecke außen kann rutschig
werden im norden deutschlands und im
süden da sind eher wenige wolken
unterwegs temperaturen sinken auf minus
drei grad im osten deutschlands und 0
grad im westen
an den alpen ist es deutlich kälter mit
minus 10 grad
sonniges wetter erwartet uns vor allem
zwischen emsland und der nordsee und im
südwesten deutschlands nach osten hin
ist es bewölkt und die temperaturen
erreichen höchstwerte von 0 grad im
vogtland und elf grad richtung oberrhein
das ist die temperaturspanne in
deutschland morgen
wir schauen auf die nächsten tage am
mittwoch gibt es viel sonnenschein in
der südhälfte deutschlands nach norden
mehr wolken und hier kann es etwas
regnen bei sechs bis zwölf grad und
donnerstag gibt es bis 15 grad ist es
trocken freitag erreicht uns aber im
norden zumindest kühlere luft damit ein
schöner abend